- Hi everyone, I'm John Cena.
I'm going to be put in
a date-like scenario
with people whom have asked me questions.
This should be very fun.
(slow jazz music)
- Hey John Cena, I'm
super excited for our date
and I just saw the movie
Blockers so I was wondering,
if you had to butt chug
a beer, what kind of beer
would you butt chug and why?
- That's a great question.
You ever seen a four
ounce can of Budweiser?
That's why.
Because it's a four ounce can.
- ♪ Hey John. ♪
♪ If you could only read one
book for the rest of your life ♪
♪ which book would it be? ♪
- ♪ I don't have jerky but
a simple melody can answer ♪
♪ This question ♪
♪ The simple work of one book compiling ♪
♪ All books in the history of mankind ♪
which would cut off
today so I wouldn't get
anything past today, but like,
if the Library of Congress
were to make one book out
of all their material.
Man, I started off good thinking
all I needed was a chorus
and then it kind of got to spoken word
and now I'm just answering the question.
Aw, shucks, if I only had jerky.
- I'm so excited for our first date.
- I am excited for--
- I just have one question.
Do you manscape?
- Do I manscape?
Um, if you've seen anything
that I've been a part of,
yes, from here down
is well taken care of.
So, yes, there's no
other way to answer it.
Yes.
- So Mister Cena, do you like
to kiss on the first date?
- Uh, that depends.
In this date-like scenario, I'm gonna pass
because I would be licking
a LED screen which is, uh,
I think it's fetish worthy
but I don't know if we're all,
I think it weirds people out.
But if it's with the right person, yes.
- Hey John Cena, I'm
just gonna call you John.
- Sure.
- I feel like we're there already.
What makes you cry and why?
- So, person in the black dress,
I'm just gonna call you Gold Necklace,
'cause I feel we're there already,
what makes me cry?
Well, there are different types of crying,
we all know that.
There's the type of cry
when you're depressed
and you're kind of down on yourself.
There's the type of emotional cry
when you watch the Notebook.
There's also the type of
happy cry when you watch
something like a moment
in sport when maybe
your team wins for the
first time in so long
and you cry tears of joy.
All of those things kind
of move me, as well as
like, weird dramas too.
I cry during watching The
Darkest Hour, that gives you
kind of an idea of
where I'm at as a crier.
But I think we're there
already so I can share that.
- Hey John Cena, before I
go on a date with anybody,
I have to know the answer to
this very important question.
Do you believe in ghosts?
- You've already sunk your own ship
because we're already
on a date-like scenario
which means that you're
lying only to yourself.
You can't go around saying
things like I only do this
if I get the answer to
this question because
we're already here.
This is already happening
so you're not a person
of your word which means
you can't be trusted
which means you have to work
on yourself and establish trust
and that totally got
me out of the question
of do I believe in ghosts or not which
I'm pretty proud of that.
- If for some reason I had
a giant pimple on my back,
and I could not reach it,
would you pop it for me?
- We're virtually meeting
and you're asking me
to be an aesthetician.
I am not qualified nor do I want to posses
the skills of an
aesthetician and therefore,
there probably would
be some medical concern
in the incorrect practice
of me taking care of your
lesion, boil, wart,
whatever you would call
the growth on your back.
I would just see it and
only it which would lead
to awkward conversation.
- I wanted to know what are
your top five favorite movies?
- Top five favorite movies,
those are good questions.
I was enthralled by the
concept of the Matrix
so I would say the Matrix.
I love the way Star Wars tells movies
so I must say Star Wars.
2001: Space Odyssey is real good.
Caddyshack is in there.
I'm a big Dangerfield guy.
And I'm gonna quit with four,
leaving one open for debate
'cause when I give my list,
everybody would be like
I can't believe you picked those movies
and didn't pick this movie.
Well, I'm leaving you
one spot so you can put
your movie in there.
- I wanna know what you're
working on right now
because I saw you in
Trainwreck and I haven't seen
Blockers yet but I know you're in it.
What are you working on now?
- That's a great question.
Head on over to YouTube
Red where you can see
Dallas and Robo, which
is an animated series.
It's quite exciting.
It has myself and Kat
Dennings and remember,
it's on YouTube Red.
John Cena here after I've experienced
speed virtual question dating.
It's awesome and kind of awkward.
Would I do it again?
Sure.
(hip hop music)